foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Tuesday and we're doing a movie review
yeah more Universal movies yeah
this is one that um I had actually been
wanting to see for a long time I don't
think I actually saw this one when I was
younger unlike most of the other
Universal movies but it was one that I
uh kept hearing about because honestly I
think it was lost for a long time you
know what I mean or at least they
thought it was lost no I mean like it
like it was damaged or something damaged
or something like that they didn't like
actually refine it until like later on
and
um you know and it was actually like
really influential
on a bunch of other uh movies going
forward so I've been wanting to see it
for a really long time and then I think
shutter added it for a while although we
watched it on um two we wouldn't to be I
think it was you can watch it on there
for free
it's a short movie about an hour or
something yeah it was it's only like an
hour and 12 minutes or something like
that this movie here was frustrating
because it was the atmosphere and it was
really good it looked the sets looked
great this is just right after
Frankenstein
and um
it looked like a high-end horror movie
from the 30s which it may have been a
high-end movie had good atmosphere the
story was actually pretty good
but then the movie just kind of ends you
know not much is really resolved there
was all these little Mysteries built up
but they never really answered them
and it's just some people their car gets
stuck in a damn Landslide out in the
middle somewhere it's in Wales actually
out in hockey motherland all right I
mean it's not actually in Wales they
actually shot it on a back lot but it's
supposed to be whales
so they end up in this spooky ass Castle
with uh
this old lady and her
brother who's you know he's like old
Queen that's the same guy that played Dr
pretorius and bride of Frankincense
that's the same act okay yeah he did he
he does a good job in it and then it
okay it's kind of like a Fall of the
House Usher or the house you know from
Edgar Allan yeah that's when I'm
watching this movie that's what I
thought it was about an evil family they
never really get into the evil of what
exactly happened uh they're one of their
relatives is locked up and he's kind of
like the Devil he's a murderer he gets
out
their
their Butler is like it it is is played
by Boris Karloff with a beard and he's
kind of like Lurch and gets drunk and
tries to molest all the women just
follow him around you know yeah big time
molesting yeah
it kind of sucks because Karloff could
act his [ __ ] ass off you know if you
if you want to see The Mummy that's
[ __ ] Carlos [ __ ] bad most badass
monster movie where he actually plays a
role and it's a lot like Dracula you
know
uh he plays this old Egyptian sorcerer
but in this one he's just Frankenstein
with a beard basically well this was
only a year after Frankenstein and it's
the same director this is James whale in
case you guys don't know this is the
movie that he made between Frankenstein
and the Invisible Man like the Invisible
Man came out the year after this it's
kind of a [ __ ] roll for him he just
[ __ ] walks around and throws things
uh he doesn't really say much he's dumb
mute he can't he can't [ __ ] speak
stupid he sh he actually should have
been one of the brothers like the main
brother that way they could have
highlighted his acting skill you know
[ __ ] Karloff could act
it was just kind of waste of of uh man
it's just it's frustrating just because
the way the story was written it
definitely like something's missing
it's like something it did kind of
because I was really into it now don't
like go into it thinking it's like a
horror horror movie it's actually like a
black comedy it's more like a comedy
like horror comedy and it's not
Supernatural Like There's No Monsters or
anything like that
um but there's like such great build up
like you said and there's like a lot of
kind of funny [ __ ] in there yeah it's
like it's rocking it's going loud this
is a pretty good movie
go ahead but then it but then it just
kind of like like a fizzled yeah the end
of it kind of fizzled out and I'm not
sure like when we were watching it you
know when I read later I don't think
anybody specifically said this but they
said oh you know it was lost for a long
time or like the first reel was damaged
or something like that and I was just
kind of like well maybe they had to
Cobble it together and like maybe
because it definitely felt like
something was missing from the end but
I'm not really sure
and I the thing about it this was
pre-code okay and like you can tell that
like in some of the characters like
particularly the one of the characters
who's A Chorus girl but they make it
pretty obvious that she's like a
prostitute like pretty much well I think
that was kind of one of the same well I
know that but it's like they didn't
actually use that word but she does like
straight up say you know um I give him
money and like you know what that means
right or something like that like she
says stuff something like that so it's
clear that that's supposed to be like
what she is yeah but um so there's that
kind of stuff going on in there like
some of this stuff for the 30s is like
pretty
scandalous but
um that's I kind of feel like a lot of
this stuff about like this cursed family
or what was going on with them was kind
of like implied more than stated
outright yeah I I don't know
they imply well there there's an
accusation that they killed one of the
sisters right Rachel and they hit it you
never see this it's just that the guy
that they have locked up claims that had
happened but he's evil so it probably
didn't happen or but you know you don't
know he gets out and he tries to burn
the whole place down and
which is funny because dude probably
weighs [ __ ] 95 pounds he looks like
he's about five foot tall who's the guy
that plays Saul yeah the pyromaniac yeah
he's he's Italian dude he is very very
small he looks like a little [ __ ] but
I said he will he has crazy strength
because he's insane he's like a little
Leprechaun running around trying to set
fire to the curtains well he succeeds in
setting fires at the curtains that one
boy yeah you meet the patriarch and he's
up in his master bedroom
laying on this huge bed and it's a woman
you can tell it's a woman that didn't
put a beard on yeah it's weird it's and
she was in like a lot of other movies
but they credited her as
um as John whatever her I can't remember
what her real last name was but like she
wasn't actually a well-known actress so
I think
like I said this had like same mango
just brought up that this had a lot of
the same kind of humor that Bride of
Frankenstein had and like I said it was
it was James whale and a lot of his
stuff had a real camp like sensibility
to it because he was like an openly gay
man like you know there's a lot of gay
stuff in this there is yeah there is
Yeah well yeah to be honest there was a
lot of that in old Hollywood movies it's
just that they couldn't State the [ __ ]
outright they had to be like kind of a
little bit on the down low about it yeah
to be an adult of the era to understand
he's implied right like and I think they
knew what they were looking at most of
the time I think they knew what it was
back then a lot of people really don't
realize that the 1920s man they've
Rewritten history these kids running
around they they've Rewritten history so
many times the 1920s especially the Baby
Boomers the Baby Boomers want to think
that they're responsible for everything
that they fixed to the world they
brought out a section but man the sexual
Revolution happened in the 1920s
they just don't want to say that the
Roaring twatties is when the sexual
Revolution happened and it wasn't the
first one and not in America the first
one was like in the 1770s
well like we said before it's always
like yeah so you know they were
doing all kinds of [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
that you would think that they didn't do
back then yeah they were doing it back
then
yeah and uh but it's a good movie
uh if you're an adult you can read it
read in between the lines you know more
about what they're talking about the
brother you know he's definitely uh he's
a queer character
um yeah he's gay
um and they don't re the the his sister
is uh
they never really say what her problem
is she's just kind of mean and deaf is
she just wow
also she watches Gloria Stewart like get
she doesn't get naked but because
somebody said yeah she must have been a
lesbian because yeah Mega said Gloria
Stewart looks great in her nightwear
yeah she does yeah yeah she's hot did
you have two hotties in this there are
yeah there's like there's hot ladies in
there yeah um and I think the old lady
must have been a lesbian oh there he
implied that and then
the dad are they implying that the dad
was was a transvestite or a transsexual
that could be because there had to be
some reason I don't like know because
they very specifically say that that's a
man that's a male character like the
Patriarchs but then when you go up there
like yeah like she has a beard but
she's talking in her regular voice which
is a very which is a woman's voice yeah
so it doesn't seem like they're trying
to be like oh won't this so it's like
I'm not really sure like what I think
that the whole implication was that this
whole family is degenerate or cursed or
something like that so they were just
trying to make them seem other I guess
well like you said the director was gay
yeah so I think he's just talking about
coming from an unusual family kind of
like the monsters or The Adams Family
this is not the family that fits on the
Block this is kind of like an ostracized
family that's not really fitting in
they're golfed out for like [ __ ] yeah
they're like The Adams Family yeah
they're like they're all weirdos of one
stripe or another yeah and it said that
it said that the patriarch up there
who's to Mia is seems transsexual to me
um
that he had these wild parties with
these people that would come over so
what the [ __ ] are we talking about here
you know what I mean is it orgies are we
talking about just places like
mannequins where we hang out you know
it's they're just saying they're just
they were partying hard all right and it
must have been
sexual type stuff you know I would I
thought that was the implication because
like the old woman the deaf old woman
just kept talking about like sin and
sisters regretting it I guess so either
that or go that's what I mean gets her
ass locked up or something yeah because
it's like well she was like bumming
everyone out man like she was probably
like no fun yeah so they're like well
why don't you just like stay in your
room then and we'll just like have fun
and party down here
like well all that but I guess like I
said I guess the implication but the
weird thing about it though is that when
they finally meet the patriarch of the
family who's like 102 they say he's 102
right yeah he seems like like a nice
person like he doesn't seem like no he's
a good guy the only really bad person is
Saul yeah he's threatening to burn it
all down he's gonna burn it all down but
he's clearly just like crazy he's evil
and [ __ ] and then and the Boris Karloff
character he's
um you know he's kind of like
evil too but really only when he drinks
they said he he gets drunk and then he
lets Saul out of his room because they
keep Saul locked up because otherwise
he'll burn the whole [ __ ] down yeah
because he's crazy like he's an Adam's
Family type thing it's yeah it does seem
very much now this was based on a novel
The Novel was actually called benighted
and it came out in 1927 so like you know
five years before this movie by JB
Priestly and I think as far as I know
like there's not much of a synopsis
about the novel like on Wikipedia But
the movie was like a pretty faithful
adaptation of the story
um but I don't think it was as funny
like I think the comedy was more like
added in the movie version but the book
is kind of more like because JB
Priestley was like a British writer so I
guess it was kind of more like a like a
parody of like the English class system
you know what I mean yeah
um which there's a little bit of that in
this but I don't think it comes across
as much as maybe it would to like a
British audience perhaps
you know I'm not entirely sure about
that to me I I just figured you know it
was like The Adams Family in the House
of Usher and it's just um people that
evidently mainstream society would
consider to be degenerate uh but
they're just people you know and then
they got one one family member who's
gonna try to burn it all down the
normies show up and say hey the
landslide this might knock this place
down and then the the gay dude says oh
no this this uh this Castle is built on
a foundation of Rock so families like
this are going to be around forever and
I think is what what that implied
um
it was an interesting movie it's just
that it didn't have a good enough ending
yeah it needed more of a Punchy ending I
feel like I actually really liked it up
till then yeah the ending was
disappointing you're like wait hold on
this whole movie's just about that
you know yeah I was I was kind of
expecting like a little bit more I think
yeah that's all it was and then a
certain plot twists should have been
given to us and then like you know [ __ ]
resolved and
I I think it was a
I think it was a statement it was I
think it was a gay statement basically I
think maybe we're not gay we call it
kind of like alternative Sexuality
Statement I think as the whole movie was
I think yeah that's how I picked it up
you got the lecherous drug who tries to
molest the women
you got the old gay waspy guy who never
hooked up with you know with it with a
family and he was like afraid of
everything like he doesn't want to go
upstairs like to get the lamp he's like
wigging out about it and we need to even
carry the lamp you had the uh the gender
bending patriarch
the deaf old lady who never got any
but but they but that they kind of imply
is maybe that she's she's lesbian
probably well because yeah she kind of
goes in the room like because Gloria
Stewart is going there to like to change
into her dinner clothes yeah and I'm
like is that old bat just gonna like sit
there on the bed and watch her and I'm
like oh I guess so yeah okay I mean like
I said she doesn't get naked her a
little bit a little bit and kind of came
up on her and she's ah yeah you know so
yeah it was a little it was a little
weird they're all a little gropey family
there was a little Ruby yeah
yeah but yeah so somebody said um that
they heard that this was um a
uh this this influenced The Rocky Horror
Picture Show and yes it did sure uh big
time I can see it so yeah so I'm right
I'm picking up on I picked up on the gay
Vibe yeah there's a well that's the
thing it's like because like I said
there's like This Old House these people
live here and then on this same night
because there's this horrible storm that
causes kind of a landslide so they have
like actually two kind of sets of people
that show up you have like a a normie
set and a wild set yeah because like the
first set is like a normie set it's like
a married couple and uh and [ __ ] and
then like you get Charles Lawton playing
a guy named I think his name is Sir
porterhouse like Sir William porterhouse
yeah I'm like oh heir to the stake
Fortune yeah I guess and and he has a
chorus girl girlfriend who like who
later says because she actually ends up
falling in love with um with the other
guy like I think the character played by
Melvin Douglas like they fall in love
like immediately yeah but she's gonna
marry her immediately her hook her ass
yeah it's [ __ ] funny and then all of
a sudden there's this triangle that
shows up it's these two girl two dudes
try to kind of agreeing to share this
girl to wear or to pass her off but
they're all gonna be good friends type
of [ __ ] didn't you pick that up on that
[ __ ]
what I don't know what you're talking
about she said I'm gonna go with this
guy we're gonna get married yeah then
the two dudes kind of friendship kinda
oh okay I get what you're saying so it's
like it was kind of like a the two dudes
were actually sitting like way closer
way too close to each other yeah so so
it was you know you just got
yeah and they're just basically well
because okay so they were talking about
[ __ ] just kind of a loose sexual it's
made clear that Charles Lawton's
character porterhouse which has every
time they said his name I just laughed
um but yeah well I'm a fat boy he's one
of the good characters he's funny well
Charles Lawton is like super famous I
think this is one of his first uh
because he's a British actor but I think
this was one of his first American
movies but he was in a [ __ ] done later
so um so it's pretty clear that he's
paying the girl but not to have sex she
says you know he pays me but he just
like wants to talk and cuddle and [ __ ]
like like so he's one of those because I
guess didn't they say he had a wife that
died and so like he just has her like
you know there it's a secretary to
comfort him or whatever so then like she
falls in love with Melvin Douglas's
character and
um you know so Melvin Douglas like comes
to Charles Lawton and is basically like
hey I'm gonna take her off your hands or
I'm gonna marry her yeah and then he's
like okay with it you know what I mean
yeah and then they become friends and
then they like I said they're sitting
off when they have that discussion like
if you just saw that scene and like
didn't really listen to the dialogue
even if you do listen to the dialogue
I'm like are those two gonna [ __ ] yes
I'm like you know they kind of look like
they were going to as well I think the
message was was hey man it's just sex
yeah you can have her you know I was you
know she's not my girlfriend really I'm
paying her yeah because they did make it
clear though they were that he was
paying her but um
but yeah so I don't know like one of the
best things about this movie like the
Huber is pretty funny
um most of the time like I really like
um because somebody was saying like the
character Ernest that singer fesiger
um is the guy that played like the the
brother like the the old gay guy who was
also Dr pretorius and Bride of
Frankenstein and I think he was gay as
well like in real life you know what I
mean and James whale was obviously
uh slasher Fred said if you guys ever
see the Alfred Hitchcock classic Rebecca
thank you mango yeah that's right I
meant meant to mention that Charles
Lawton was married to Elsa Lanchester
who played uh the Bride of Frankincense
okay so there you go another hottie yeah
um I think what the pro I think what the
deal was with this movie okay you got a
gay director in this in these days they
really it would have been impolite and
it wouldn't have really been had
mainstream acceptance for them to
condone any kind of alternative
lifestyle
so what you do is is you have a horror
movie type situation where you kind of
show these uh
or you imply these these alternative
lifestyle choices right you just kind of
show them to the audience and there's
some humor involved and some spooky [ __ ]
happens but it's never really quite
condoned
so that way you could say well these are
bad people yeah you know what I mean you
can wash your hands of it
but I think it was just ex I think they
were just sending the message out that
yeah we know this exists
you know and we know you guys are out
there you know I think that's all it is
I mean there was a lot of like I said
you'd be surprised if you kind of like
look back through the history of all the
movies because there have been an entire
like you know [ __ ] scholarly works
and everything like books and stuff
written on it about all of the you know
coded queer characters that they had in
movies back then a lot of the gangster
movies had it in it yeah but like you
couldn't come out and say it but
everybody that was kind of I guess
everybody kind of knew the score you
know what I mean I think was it Little
Caesar actually had a bunch of
kind of gay themes happening in it
um remember that one that was the one
it was a gangster movie like Italian
gangster movie it kind of implies that
that gangster was like a bisexual
which that would have made sense because
Clyde Barrow was and a lot of those guys
from the Roaring 20s were you know if I
could because they were in and out of
prison all the time and it was just part
of their prison culture of the Dead you
know and uh is so it's kind of portrayed
in the movies
but they had to do it in a veiled manner
yeah well I've seen some uh some critics
speculate that the um you know Dr
Frankenstein in the original
Frankenstein movie was coded bisexual
yeah which I could see that I could see
remember you remember what the point I
don't remember exactly but I'm just
saying that that's something that a lot
of people bring up the Bride of
Frankenstein is definitely definitely
these two dudes
or this trying to make a dab AI sex bot
well and it's not even so much that
they're also trying to take over the
process of birth like they're trying to
take it away from women because like
they don't homunculi and [ __ ] right like
they want to make some like they can't
like give birth to a human so they're
like trying to go about it like in a
different way so there's that kind of
[ __ ] too which I think we brought up on
the Bride of Frankincense the bride had
the heart of a hooker that came out and
the brain was a synthetic brain made by
the other guy yeah it was AI it was an
AI sex bot that's what they're talking
about pretty much yeah and she had to
buy the bones of a 16 year old
and the best flesh that they could find
they're talking about a sex bot man come
on
slasher friend said if you guys ever see
the Alfred Hitchcock classic Rebecca
there is an implication that Mrs Danvers
was homosexual uh and mega said yeah Mrs
Danvers certainly has a thing for
Rebecca that's another movie Rebecca at
the Alfred Hitchcock I didn't see this
movie
um yeah that's based on the Daphne du
maurier novel we should probably do that
one of these days because that's a
classic uh Slash Fred said since it's
December one of these days on your
Wednesday show you should do one of the
classic ghost stories Like A Christmas
Carol yeah maybe we could do that I mean
I think the um
one of my favorite ones which is the
George C Scott one I think is free on
YouTube at the moment uh mango also said
JB Priestly who wrote the book that the
old dark house was based on uh wrote one
of the greatest mystery detective
stories ever and Inspector Calls oh yeah
I've heard of that but I never read it I
highly recommend the 1945 film
adaptation okay well I will have to look
that up I mean the thing about it is
that what happened with this movie like
I think it did okay but it didn't do as
well as Frankenstein and I think
Universal eventually lost the rights to
the novel so they had to pull it so the
the novel got remade again in 1963 by
William Castle but I don't think I've
seen that version you know what I mean
but that seems like something that'd be
right up William Castle's alley he did
all those kind of like
cheesy like movies wrong you know with
all those ones with Vincent Price like
House on Haunted Hill all that kind of
stuff you know what I mean yeah so they
did another one in 1963 that was the old
dark house like another version of it
and I think Hammer had a a hand in that
one as well
but but like I said this one this movie
was lost for a long time like because
they had lost the rights to the novel
and I think it just kind of got I don't
know stuffed in a shelf or something
somewhere and uh they didn't know where
it was for a long time or they only had
like parts of it or it was in bad
condition so they actually like found it
later on it kind of got shitty reviews
at the time I could see why you know
what I mean the ending is not good
enough for this movie that that needed
to go out with a bang
I did kind of feel like it needed more
of like it didn't have a clear head a
big ending like the ending was just kind
of like that was it yeah so this is what
this movie's about because it was such a
lot of cool build up like all these
people like show up at this thing and
there's all these [ __ ] sketchy
[ __ ] like in this house and
you're like what the hell is going on
with these people at least in the House
of Usher the house [ __ ] fell down
into the ground
yeah you know what I mean it was
destroyed so you had something to look
at and they were you know they were all
you know being destroyed in their own
but nothing really happens at the end a
fight happens and somebody gets killed
and then the other guy gets locked up
and that's it yeah like one well yeah
like the one guy gets killed and then
the other guy you think he's dead but
then he's just wounded and then like he
wakes up and he's like hey I'm gonna
marry the hooker oh that's right he
didn't die yeah he didn't die yeah the
crate the the the crazy uh pyromaniac
yeah that's right the little the little
crazy [ __ ] little munchkin yeah but
yeah I think he's the only one that died
right I think so women no he didn't die
they picked him up and took him back to
his room
I thought they said he was dead I don't
think so well okay I got I got the plot
synopsis I got the plot synopsis
yeah he died he died he did die okay
they just took his body up there because
I guess they were just gonna stick it up
there and figure out what to do with it
yeah I guess might as well like the
house was just like [ __ ] shitty ass
conditions yeah I mean I don't know
um but yeah so oh and I should say too
like when we were talking about like the
whole like coded queer thing is the the
last name of the family is Femme yeah I
noticed that yeah another thing that was
weird is that the uh the crazy power
Maniac guy's name was Saul yeah and if I
remember correctly I think in the Old
Testament wasn't uh Saul and David
yeah well they he brings this that up in
the movie like the biblical yeah there's
like solid reference he has like a big
like monologue about it that's like that
was like a homosexual relationship in
the yeah in the Bible in the Old
Testament so yeah they brought it up
yeah so that's what they're talking
about definitely
yeah I'm sure it is it's like it seems a
lot more
overt in this one
I don't know it was pretty overt and
Bride of Frankenstein too I guess but in
this one it just seemed like there was
more of that going on yeah mango says
the William Castle version is not very
good it's more like a slapstick comedy
which this one kind of is but I kind of
feel like the humor in this one there's
a little bit of kind of slapsticky stuff
but this one is kind of more like
I don't know like the dialogue and like
is kind of like witty so I kind of feel
like it's more that but it does have a
little bit of a slapstick it should have
been about another 20 minutes of this
movie that had needed to have a proper
ending
you know yeah I would have liked for
there to have been like I said I haven't
read the book so I don't know like how
the book is resolved I would have liked
for them to well one I would have liked
for their beats of like more of a battle
like with Saul yeah like maybe he could
have escaped earlier like I don't know
he escaped pretty early I guess like
yeah 100 year old guy up there that they
left that was they left that hanging
and like I said he didn't seem like a
bad guy like he seemed like a perfectly
nice person yeah like he didn't seem
like some degenerator or anything he was
just like an old man in bed he's like
yeah this is kind of cool
you know we used to party here
we were partying that's all he talked
about yeah I think it would have been it
would have been scarier for like some of
that because I mean the Boris Karloff
character he was like the scariest
character and he wasn't scary to me and
he wasn't all that yeah well that's what
I'm that's the point that I'm making is
that not everybody like I guess this was
just supposed to be a comedy mostly yeah
but it did have horror elements but like
I said it's not Supernatural it's
basically just kind of like like you
said it's like Fall of the House of
Usher I thought it was gonna be a
haunted house movie but it wasn't it's
really not it's really not it's not
haunted would have been better if it had
if it had been a haunted house movie
yeah that had been cool if it ever been
a ghost has there been ghosts and stuff
and yeah and that would it but like I
said I think the original book was more
supposed to be like a comedy of manners
type thing like kind of poking fun of at
the English class system okay so I think
that's maybe what they were going for
with it and then it just had a little
bit of like a haunted house thing but
the house isn't haunted necessarily it's
because it's not Supernatural uh Slash
of red also said in the other Alfred
Hitchcock classic rope there were some
implications that the two killers were
homosexual as well yeah that I wonder
was that based on particular
murderers I haven't seen rope in a
really really long time that's the one
that's it like entirely in one room
you know have you ever seen it it's good
um slasher Fred also said on the show
Sesame Street there were some
implications that Bert and Ernie Were
Gay I always thought they were when I
was a kid
it never like occurred to me that they
weren't just they stepped in two
different beds but they were side to
side side by side I always thought they
were brothers
they don't look alike that well I guess
they kind of look like yeah I just
because you know as far as like puppets
go yeah because when I was a little kid
you know but all the puppets looked like
that so they didn't really have like a
family resemblance because all the
puppets look like that yeah I just
thought they were brothers
really yeah well my friends Jimmy and
Mike were brothers they slept in the
same bed they said bed same bedroom they
were yeah a lot of brothers yeah so they
were they were on and bunk beds there's
only a couple well yeah when I mean when
I was little when me and my brother were
little I slept in a bunk bed and my
little brother yeah so I just thought
they were they were brothers I thought
they were little kids
they're supposed to be kind of like
little kids they literally living like
little kids
they had their own house though they
didn't have parents well it's never
really brought up
that's true yeah I mean maybe they did
have parents who just you know yeah I
was I it occurred to me I always thought
they were adults well at least Bert
seems like an adult Ernie doesn't seem
like when you're watching peanuts they
very very rarely ever deal with adults
except yeah but teachers well their
parents sound like that too yeah but but
you're aware that they have parents and
teachers that there are adults in there
with it's just they're just not
important I didn't think about it
because they were [ __ ] puppets Jenny
I knew
I'm not worried about them well I know
how they reproduce and well I wasn't
worried about it either it's just it
didn't occur to me I knew there were
hands in there you know what I mean
oh my God yeah that's like really really
funny [ __ ] trying to be all Spock
with me
why why was I trying to be spot you know
being logical about about what they know
talking about trying to rationalize
puppets I was just a little kid I wasn't
trying to rationalize them I didn't you
know whether or not they had parents
never even [ __ ] crossed my mind
whether they had parents or not I just
thought they were kids well I thought
they were thought they were like
brothers I mean I just thought they were
adults it's in I like it never occurred
to me that they were children I'm mostly
worried about Oscar I liked Oscar more
than any you know I like that I like
dogs yeah you [ __ ] come up out of
there and make my day that one in that
snuffleup I guess oh I yeah I always say
like stuff I guess I also like Snapple
obvious but I mean Oscar was clearly the
best yeah because he was just such a
commercial talking [ __ ] the whole time
yeah I'm like yeah that's he's awesome
yeah and he was like all hanging out and
being like disgusting and stuff yeah I
do I have to admit I liked Grover as
well yeah Grover Grover was pretty cool
man we need to stop talking about this
one
Mega said Oscar rocked yeah Hugo said
they're Brothers don't kill my childhood
foreign
baby yeah Leopold and Loeb that's who I
was thinking of I think I think that's
who the killers in rope were modeled off
of that's who I was thinking of so yeah
probably all right so you are you ready
to yeah to close it out all right yep so
um so yeah old dark house uh if you like
Universal maybe it's a little bit weird
for a universal movie because it's not
like Monsters and it's not Supernatural
but it was pretty influential and it's
kind of funny so it's like you might and
it's got like an All-Star cast like
there's all kind of super famous people
in it so it's you know it's fun until
the end it's a that's really the only
thing I do disappointing in I just
thought the end was like a little bit
fizzled out but other than that I
thought it was really cool and I thought
like the cinematography and everything
like that was really awesome I think it
was the same cinematographer as
Frankenstein also if I'm not mistaken so
but yeah I'm pretty sure I don't know if
it's on shutter anymore but it's um it's
on 2B like for free so you can watch it
on there so tomorrow night is our big
main show and I'm sure Zach will be very
happy to find out that we're going to be
talking about movies that were total
[ __ ] shows behind the scenes so we'll
have some fun stuff to talk about it'll
be super fun so hopefully you guys can
all uh come here for that so thanks for
dropping by thanks for super chats and
we'll see you guys again tomorrow night
bye